Hey, what's going on? It's bill burn. It's
the Monday morning podcasts for Monday,
February 10th, 2014 how's
it going? How are you? Yes,
I know.
I realize the podcast is actually
air quote on time this week.
Okay. Don't even start that
shit. It's never late. All right.
I always take on Monday mornings.
That's why I call it the Monday morning
podcast. You fucking myopic cons.
All right. The only reason why you're
getting it this early on Mondays,
because I'm taping it on Sunday. The
only reason why I'm taping it on Sunday,
which I shouldn't even be doing
because it's a day of rest. All right?
It's a day to sit back after a week of
farming. Phil give you a fucking oxygen,
some oats, whatever. You feed them
Hay. Is that what you feed them?
I know what the fuck you feed them.
All right. All I know is they don't,
they're fucking jacked and then the,
you never see them fucking
drinking a protein shake. Delia.
People would drink protein shakes,
you know something?
Years later when you get
the powder cancer, I don't
want to hear about it. Okay.
You're drinking a goddamn powdered shake.
What do you want the fucking Jetsons?
Sit down and have a pork
chop like the rest of us.
He's fucking idiot. Say they are
these goddamn workout people for.
He'd go out there and you dress like
the green lantern and then you take out
your little fucking powder thing.
He's a little thing and you shake the
thing up and then you suck it down.
Just have a fucking salad.
You know dude,
you know pissed off those people who was
selling the Twat of nature where it me,
they were actually upset so they
won't be on my podcast anyway.
They were mad.
Is this selling that box full of lies?
You're you get hungry in the
afternoon? Yeah. J what do I do?
You can have a fucking banana. Get
them an apple. You're going to be fine.
Watch the pounds melt off.
I don't need you to come over
with your tray of snacks.
Cigars, cigarettes, cigars,
cigarettes.
No Fuck Outta here.
Okay, and shame on you for
going in order in that shit.
You Lazy fucking Tba Shit.
I'm sorry.
I know you're not supposed to fat shame,
but I,
you know it's time we
start fucking some point.
You got to tell him to like, look, I
know you can't see your bootstraps,
but you still should try to reach down
and find them and pull them up over your
fucking meetings. Fat,
flabby shoulders. All right?
You ate your way into this situation.
You can eat what you eat your way out.
Just do everything that you
were doing the opposite way.
It's like playing a record
backwards, except now you're
playing it the right way.
You've been listening to it back,
which [inaudible] Sundays,
chocolate Sundae ships sharp,
right? You've got to have
it. Go on the other way.
Oh, this is some Broccoli and Brussels
sprouts. It's not a nice song.
Oh fuck.
I hate taping on Sundays.
I'm not funny on fucking Sunday Stair.
I admitted just like,
God, I need a rest. I don't
have time for this shit.
I don't have time to be
solely on a fucking Sunday.
I worked all God damn week.
Do you have any microphones?
I did fucking take out of
a Mike stand this week.
Do you understand how sore my wrist is?
The fucking,
Hey, are you guys doing
all right? All right.
Keep it going for whoever the fuck was
just on the front of me. All right.
How's it going? Oh, look
at this guy. This guy,
he's got snaps on his shirt or
the buttons too hard for you.
I'm the smartest guy ever. Fuck
his job. Look at me. I'm amazing.
I got to do that every
fucking night on Sunday.
I give it a rest.
I don't say funny things on Sundays.
So you probably ask yourself,
well,
build and why don't you just do it
on fucking Monday? I'll tell you why.
I'll tell you why. Because,
um, my wife is actually sick.
He's got a 24 hour a virus,
which I did not think was contagious.
I thought she thought she
had food poisoning is what
it was. What I thought was,
so I was laying next to her bed,
we'll use in the same fucking bathroom.
So basically I'm probably going
to get sick and the next 24 hours.
So what I'm trying to do is get this
podcast out before shit starts coming out
of me on both ends, if you know what I
mean. All right. I got the wife upstairs.
I'm downstairs. I feel like I feel
like my wife got bit by a Zombie,
you know,
and I ever upstairs chained
to the Devonport there and
I'm just waiting to see
if she's going to turn. All we need is
Brad Pitt in here telling us what to do.
We got ourselves a goddamn movie.
Um, yeah. So that's why, uh,
that's why this thing is actually
out early. And, uh, and once again,
fuck all you guys are going to be
like, oh, if she gets sick every week.
So it could be on time and fucking,
I wish the Twat of nature
on anybody who says that.
Um, all right, sorry. That was
me. It was all mean. So anyways,
this is the podcast for this week. Uh,
has anybody been watching the Olympics?
Olympics. Olympics? Yeah,
yeah, yeah. Nothing.
I actually,
I really enjoy watching the Olympics.
I like just watching in the games. I don't
like all the other horseshit. You know,
all the journalists complaining that the
water isn't running and all that type
of shit.
I mean,
am I the only guy who watched all those
cold war movies coming up when I was
growing up?
You know what it's like over there.
You got the haves and
you've got to have nots.
There's like 20 people who have some
shit over there and everybody else is
getting fucked. It's,
it's unbelievably corrupt.
You know what's going on over there,
you know,
I don't know. I don't know what
the fuck's going on of the, I just,
I just want to watch a fucking games,
you know, I get it. I get it. They don't,
they don't treat gay people the way that
they should. I mean, why, why would they,
they,
they don't even have running water over
there surprised in a club in women over
their head and dragging them down
the street by the fucking hair. Um,
have you read some of the shit that
they've said about gay people? I mean,
it's like feist is this from the,
the 18 hundreds,
some guy in the Russian government,
he, this is what he said.
Um, he told, gave,
he also told gay visitors to not touch
the kids like he's confusing pedophiles
with, with, with gay
people and fucking real,
no wonder the water's not
running over there. Now listen,
I don't want to take a bunch
of pot shots at Russia.
I don't want to do this because for
some fucking reason I actually like him.
I miss him.
They were fun.
It's like when the red sox are good
and the Yankees suck, it's no fun.
And for like the last, I dunno, 20
something years they've been there,
they're in a Rut right now. They're like
the Michigan Wolverine Football Program.
Like what the fuck happened?
What are you going to get good again?
And it's starting to get
to the point like, fuck,
are they going to turn this around?
So I dunno,
I don't even know what to tell you.
I,
you know,
I don't understand
how you can have the technology to blow
up the world and then you still not
understand humanity at that point.
Right?
Don't they get will and
grace like translated over
there? Can't they see that?
There's nothing to worry about.
If you guys watched any of the, any
of the Games I actually watched, uh,
I watched some of the,
the cross country ski and I don't know
if I'm a f and I in some of the speed
skating,
like I watched this,
the snowboarding I think
is fucking amazing,
but after a while it just looks like
they're all doing the same trick. Okay.
And I don't need a bunch of shit from
people in their teens and twenties with
half your head shaved and the rest of
it looking like a comb over. I get it.
I'm old.
I can't tell the difference.
We've seen a backside
fakey in a fucking gumby.
Twizzler three 60, whatever the
fuck you, I don't know. I'm amazed.
I don't know how they do it,
but I can only watch like four runs.
The, you know, uh, I did just
all looks the same. I don't know.
I know what they're doing. You fucking,
you go down the hill, you jump on the,
on the railing or the banister,
whatever it is.
You do a little grindy thing and then
you land and then you in and then you
fucking do a little low.
Whoop de do B. Do you grab it?
You grab this and grabbing the board
with the hands. That's a big move.
This is me trying to explain it.
And then I also learned that when you go
to land you're actually looking up the
hill. You have your head looking
up. They I haven't seen my,
I would have looked down the hill.
He supposed to look up the hill.
Okay.
All right. I've learned that, eh? Uh,
okay.
I Dunno. Then you do a lot of high
fiving and hugging of other um,
other people that you're
trying to beat for some reason.
There's a lot of comradery and that sport.
Other than that,
I don't know shit about it,
but the speed skating I like and
a cross country skiing. Go figure.
I liked that shit cause it
makes me want to go work out.
Like I was watching the
women doing it and I'm like,
they have burned so many calories,
they don't even have titties anymore.
Can you imagine? I could get rid of the
giant teddy that's right above my pubes.
If I started cross country ski,
that's what I'm getting out of it though.
These women were flying
okay up the Goddamn hill and then down
Ellie actually they said this year they
might actually hit speeds of 50 miles an
hour and they are so fucking exhausted
by the end of it.
You cross the finish line,
they all of them collapsed
and just fall in the snow.
Like they were going to make a snow angel
and then they just passed out from too
much booze or something and then
they're laying on the fucking ground
doing that shit and I'm just like, I
dunno. There's something about you don't,
it is, I'm not fast. So
I like endurance shit.
You know gymnastics and that type of shit
for having a hang from some do an iron
cross. Like I look at that stuff
and I actually think like, you know,
if I tried to do that
long enough I could do it.
I couldn't do it at an Olympic
level, but I could do it. All right.
I can watch a guy run a four 40
all day long dunk a basketball.
I hit a fucking home run.
Okay.
In a major league stadium. I'm never
going to be able to do that shit.
Did I just say I could do an iron cross?
Maybe I'm already getting sick right
now. Maybe I'm a fuck you. I can do it
all.
I need some rings.
Yeah,
and an old tree to hang them
from. Oh my God. Can you imagine?
What do you what?
What is even,
what is the muscle you tear trying
to fucking do that. That's your lats.
I want to how long that takes a little
district. All right, so all you would do,
you'd fucking hanging from the tree.
You know, once your wife is like dog,
so we don't hurt yourself.
Once you get through that,
okay.
You know a few people with kids and
I'm just putting it up for the kids.
Don't worry, I'll put some match down or
put some leaves here. There'll be fine.
I figured what you gotta do,
you hang the,
have things hanging down and you got
to get into the dip position first
and then what you do is you gradually
start bringing it out and then when you
start feeling the fire under your armpits,
you bring it back real quick.
And just every day you go out there or
every other day and he tried to go a
little bit farther as
is that how you doing?
Anybody can anybody who listens
to this podcast do an iron cross?
Do I have to be wearing like those pants
like the feet pajama grape smuggling,
fucking a lower pants,
lower pants, lower leotard,
section of the pants there. Ah, fuck.
Why do I try to do this on Sunday
five this is why I don't go to church.
It's just Sunday. So you
know, I don't fucking know.
I'm always coming back from the
road. I'm always traveling, you know,
I fly back and then I'm just, I
just lay here catatonic. I'm I,
this isn't what I'm supposed to be
doing here. Trying to be fucking funny.
Anyways, I had a great show this
weekend. I was actually out in, uh,
Minneapolis,
Minnesota at this casino,
I believe was called treasure island. I
was there, so fucking quick, I flew in,
I did the show and I came right back out.
It was like minus two degrees the
entire fucking time I was there.
And that is a level of
cold you don't like.
I love the winter.
I don't give a shit until it gets down.
Once it gets into the teens,
that's when I give a fuck. That's what
I'm like, all right. Enough already.
But I don't even mind if it's in
the teens and Christmas is coming.
It's when it's in the teens and
it's just February or January.
That's when it's fucking miserable.
And it was so fucking cold out there.
Even people from Minnesota, we're
saying that it was like cold, but, um,
anyways, I went out there
and, uh, had a great time.
Thank you to everybody who showed up.
I'm
still on the wagon. You know,
it's funny, after the show, um,
I was hanging, it was me and the other
rack that was out there. Jade cat,
a prater hope I said that right.
Um,
I've never known how to say the last name.
I came fucking read who fucking
killed him in front of me. By the way,
I had a great set.
So afterwards we're hanging in,
we're hanging with the promoter and I'm
sitting at the bar and I'm not drinking
and I'm fucking drinking oh duels
and like how many, oh duals.
He literally going to have,
so I get one, oh duals.
And I'm just sitting there like,
all right,
I'll sip on this fucking thing and
smoke God damn cigar or whatever.
And um, so people after
the show and go, Hey,
can I get you a drink and get your
drink? I'm like, I'm like, no,
I really appreciate it. Thank you for
coming out, but I'm not drinking. Sorry.
You know, you know, whatever. Get Jay
born if she wants one of Blah, blah, blah.
So then people started buying me
rounds. They were buying me. Oh duals.
So then I'm like, well I got
drink it, somebody gave it
to me. So like an asshole.
All the weight that I've been losing,
cause I haven't boozed in like two weeks.
Like, now I'm just sitting here pounding
out duels pounding, pounding, oh,
duels.
The dumbest fucking like the emptiest of
all empty calories. Just sitting there,
slam of things. I got to tell you
something for a non alcohol beer, it's,
it ain't that fucking bad.
And if you have to be at a bar,
I dunno. I think I followed
it. I think I phoned.
See I never yarn on Monday
mornings. I think I found, um,
I think I go on a nice little run here.
If I can just still have my cigars,
I have to have some sort of vice.
Um,
well that'd be bad if I go back upstairs.
Right.
And my poor wife flag, you know, she's,
she's up there right now in Gatorade,
saltine cracker, um, hell right now.
And she's cool too. She's cool about
it. She's cool with me being down here.
You know, a lot of women would
be like, why can't a conference,
you get at least sit in the chair near me.
I can't believe that I have, you know,
and then you get sick and they're fucking,
they don't give a shit.
Right. Um, anyways,
I didn't tell you guys this. I actually
bought off of Ebay. I bought a fucking,
I bought a drum kit.
You know the one thing that sucks about
drums as you cannot play them in a,
unless you get it soundproofed in
your fucking house. So I actually,
I got some drum cases and I'm going
to bring these fucking things up.
I can't wait to play these goddamn
things. I get an old Ludwig Kit. Um,
I know what you guys are saying.
Send me a picture and that senior picture,
just know that there it's an
old Ludwig kit. I do time.
I will and do time. Let me get my
drumming up to a certain fucking level.
Cause I know I've promised you guys that
I was going to start doing drum covers.
I gotta I'll fucking do one.
I just got to get somebody to videotape
these fucking things in an edit it and
all that shit. I just don't know
how to do that. And furthermore,
I don't want to learn how to do it.
I don't need another goddamn
hobby. I just, I don't know.
You know what it is. I, I
have like computer phobia.
That's basically what earlier when I was
trashing everybody with the new phones
and all that, part of that was true. Like,
I really think you should pay down your
debt before you get another flat screen
TV. Before you get another fucking phone.
I can, if I could just get anything,
just get something through
to the listeners on this
God damn podcast other than
to go after what you want in life
as soon as you can. It would be,
you know,
to just pay down your credit cards.
Don't start a fucking
life, a death, death,
life of debt before you even get married
and start having kids and then come out
of it, you know, 40,
50 fucking years later when you're
in your sixties or seventies. Um,
I'm telling you just within your means
and you will have the gift of free time,
you'll actually get a good night's
fucking sleep. Um, but anyways,
yeah.
Yeah. So, but that, um, generally
speaking like I have, I have major, uh,
I don't know, I learned a lot about
myself in the last week. Like, my wife
finally convinced me that I have add and
I know a lot of you guys who listen to
this shit. I'll probably
just laughing like, yeah. How
the fuck did she know that?
You know why? Cause I'm the one
trapped in this fucking skull. Okay,
sure. You guys have problems too.
No, fucking come at me like that.
Trying to open up here.
Um,
I have the yellow wind screen
on the mic this week. Okay.
Trying to come from my hat here.
I get a little sunshine on the Mike here.
Um,
and I didn't think
I didn't think she was right
and she was like, no, she goes,
I went on a website and I looked up a,
and you have every fucking symptom and
I always just thought add was just a
crutch. Like people, I'm sorry, I have
add. I'm sorry. Every add. Oh, I got,
I have add. I saw people, you know, I
drove into the back of your car. Sorry.
I have add. Like it just seemed
like this fucking excuse.
It seems something like for just
something that week people said.
So, um, I was just like,
no, I'm, um, I'm stupid. Um,
and uh, I need to read more. That's
basically how I looked at it,
which still might be the case. But, um,
I finally understood what
she was saying cause she,
she read some of the symptoms and then
I was sitting on the couch and I was
talking to her about the Patrice
O'Neal benefit coming up.
And I was saying how happy I was that,
you know,
we're doing it two years in a row,
we're helping out all the
people that he loved. Well,
but now people that you know,
okay,
you know, diabetes, stroke and that type
of thing, we've given some money to them.
And I'm really talking about how
site Diane, that everybody, you know,
bought the tickets and opie and Anthony
helped out in all the comics. Like,
I mean, I have more than enough
comedians on the show this year,
but she said everybody loved Patrice,
want to be on it.
So I'm in the middle of this heartfelt
conversation with my wife and in,
and I'm sitting on one end of the couch.
She's on the end.
And I sit there and I kind of leaned my
head back and I look up at the ceiling
and I'm in the middle is talking about
how much I love for Teresa and how much I
miss him. And I looked up and I went,
oh, a spider, there's a spider up there.
And I just started talking about
the spider. And then I hear her,
she starts laughing and
I look at her like, what?
And it was one of those things
she needed to have to say it.
She just had this look in her eye,
like that shit we were
talking about earlier as you
leave buried her face in the
pillow and just started laughing at me.
And I was like,
and I actually know typical guy thing,
I had to try to defend myself. Mike, no,
I mean there's a spider and how
do you not address the spider?
And then I really thought about it later,
like the level of,
of emotional shit that
I was talking about.
And then just one stupid fucking
spider. Oh, there's a spider.
Like did another thing that when
I go to leave the fucking house.
Okay.
I Dunno.
Maybe I'm trying to help out other people
who might have this fucking problem
is like, and she told
me she would go, well,
you should go talk to somebody bought us.
Like,
I don't want to talk fucking
talk to somebody about it.
They're going to give me a god damn drug
that they pushed through the FDA that's
going to fuck up my liver
and do something else to me.
But I can really focus when the doctor
tells me I have this new kind of fucking
cancer,
whatever happened to just toughen it out.
You know, you fucking Rogaine
pussies just go bald like me.
Um, anyways, how many times do I say this?
What the fuck was I talking about?
The same goddamn thing. This is it.
I made your fucking problems. So she
wanted me to go talk to somebody about it.
I'm like, I'm not fucking
doing that. But uh,
I've just really noticed like the amount
of times, like take something simple.
I'll have like a grocery
list or something.
If I ever made a grocery list in my life,
let's just say for shits and giggles.
I do.
I'll have that on my or my
phone or something like that.
I have my phone and I'm going to
leave the house and I go, Oh fuck.
Where are my keys?
I need my keys.
So then I walk over and I go over
and I pick up my keys. All right.
See you later honey. And I walk
out of the house. I sit in the car,
I turn on the fucking car and then
I look around. Where's my phone?
I left it the fucking house.
Okay.
How did I do that? I had the
phone, I knew I needed the phone,
I needed the keys and it's just like I
walk up there and my brain is thinking
about 90 other fucking things other
than in somewhere in there is I need the
keys and I walk over to get the fucking
keys I guess with the same hand and I
sat down the phone. It's like,
almost like you don't, like when you,
when you're blackout drunk,
it's like technically you passed out,
but somebody is still awake in your body
walking around talking to people that
you're later going to have to apologize
for this kind of the sober version of
that. For those of you who
aren't afflicted with this,
whatever the hell I have.
Okay.
Maybe that's why I suck at reading.
I don't know what it is.
Okay.
Because I, I really want to sit here
and say that I'm not a dumb guy,
but fucking everything.
And I always talk about how much I sucked
in high school. I haven't went like,
I want one time like,
well,
we had to do a book report
and I got this book,
it was about this German shepherd in
World War Two that fall along side.
This guy who was a great fucking book.
MMM.
And uh,
I remember the first night I sat down to
read it and it took me like four hours,
couldn't have been four. It was
like three hours to read, 30 pages,
two and a half hours to
read 30 fucking pages.
And the next day I went into school. I
still remember the kid, I said this too.
I said, yeah man, it took me fucking,
I was reading the book for two and
a half hours and they were like,
how many pages? You got to say,
wow. I mean, Paige is into a,
and I said 30 and he just started
laughing at me and I said to him,
he goes, I go, what? He goes, it took you
two and a half hours to read 30 pages.
And I was like, what? I
said, I read to understand
it. He just started laughing at
me, thought that was the funny.
He thought I was trying to be funny and
what I was really was trying to convey
to him was I had to,
I kept reading paragraphs and my brain
would be thinking about other shit and I
had to go back and reread it over
and over and over and over again.
So I had to go that slowly
so I could understand it.
It was basically my naive way of I guess,
explaining.
Look. All I'm saying is if I don't
have add, I am surprisingly stupid,
but whatever.
It's helped me like maybe that's
why I can't write a fucking script,
but I can write bits cause
this this short. Right.
You know what I like about this add shit.
I can explain away all my problems.
This is phenomenal.
Hey,
guess what?
All right. Does that mean anything
to, she's looking at me right now.
She was laying down. She just picked
up her head. She was awake. By the way.
It's one of those deals with it.
She's got one year down and one year up.
You know?
Can you get any fucking,
I challenge you right now to tell me
something cuter in the animal kingdom than
a fucking jacked animal that could rip
your fucking face off that anytime it
decides to waking up from an,
from a nap with one year down in one
year up. Commit Cleo, Kimmy up buddy.
Come here. Oh, big stretch. A big stretch.
Come here. Let me fix your ear.
I'm not saying jump up on the bed.
There you go. That's her saint alone.
Sniffing the microphone. What's up buddy?
But even your head has muscles,
Huh? This is what I do every day.
Cause even,
I don't know how to express love.
This is what I do every day with Cleo.
I grab her by both ears.
Not Hard.
Now she's walking away.
I grab her by both ears and I just make
her look up at me and when she looks up
at me,
I just call it fuck.
That's how it is.
I love that dog so much.
I want to fucking tackle it every
time I see it. Is that right Cleo?
How you helping me live longer?
Because I got to take you out every day.
Fucking shits like a horse. Um, anyways.
Oh,
you know what?
We got to take a break for
some advertising that I
haven't even gotten yet,
so I'm gonna have to drop
these in. So through the magic
of radio, not of editing,
I should say, Hey, don't
wipe your ass on the rug.
You,
she rarely does that.
Still like the fucking thing. Anyways,
just making sure CJ, you go, go lay down,
um, through the magic of
editing. Here's so my or some.
Here's the first group of
advertising for this week,
okay, and now the advertising this week
dropped into the podcast to the magic of
editing. Sherry's berries. Everybody.
Hey,
how did you meet your significant?
Create another unforgettable
moment with Sherry's berries.
You can talk about learning how to give
the right gift. Finally, getting it right.
Talk about how much they enjoyed the
product. Oh, that isn't part of the copy.
I don't understand these fucking
people. All right? Giant.
Freshly dipped strawberries from Sherry's
berries starting at just 1999 for an
or a 40% savings or double
the berries for just $10 more.
You just need my code.
[inaudible] B, u r when you order,
I'm assuming it's birth,
there's, it's blank. There.
A ditch in white milk and dark chocolaty
goodness topped with chocolate chips,
decorative swizzle or nuts.
40% off from Sherry's berries.
Enormous romantic,
fresh, juicy, mouthwatering
berries right in your mouth.
Here's the only way to get this
amazing Valentine's Day gift.
Giant freshly dipped strawberries starting
at just 1999 or double the berries
for just $10 more. Visit
berries.com. That's B, e,
r r,
I e s.com.
Click on the microphone in the top
right hand corner and type in burpee.
You are areGood@berries.com. Click on the
microphone and type in Berbee. You rr.
Hurry,
offer ends on Thursday.
Oh Shit.
You know what?
I just realized I'm supposed to read
these before I read them so their copy
isn't wrong. My apologies to
everybody at Sherry's berries.
All right. The classic, the
one that everybody loves,
dollar Shave Club for a
couple of bucks a month.
Dollar Shave club.com delivers amazing
quality razors right to your front door.
Not only does it save
you a ton of cash at t,
it saves you from trudging to the
drug store for a pack of blades.
I always get stuck behind the family
of four trying to buy cream and develop
their photos from the disposable camera.
Um,
but now I don't have to do that anymore
because dollar shave club for just a
couple of bucks a month.
Amazing quality razor blades are delivered
right to your door. That's right.
No more wasting time.
And no more getting hit up for 20 bucks.
Every time you go to buy razors.
Everybody here meaning me is getting
their dollar shave club blades.
And you should too.
And here's a genius idea.
Try replacing your old shaving
cream with doctor. Easy Shave
from dollar Shave club.com trust me,
your face will thank you later.
Don't waste time at the drug store
behind the lady paying and Penny's.
Go to dollar shave club.com forward
slash [inaudible] or go to bill.com and
Click on the dollar shave club banner.
Keep your stress level lower and your
bank account balance high shave time.
Shave money. Go to dollar shave
club.com forward slash spur.
They you go look at that. I think that
was damn near perfect read. All right,
another one for Valentine's Day.
Everybody pro flowers, pro flowers.
You already got a chocolate covered
strawberries from Sherry's berries.
You got your face clean shaven from dollar
shave club. What is there left to do?
Simple.
You got to get her some flowers,
Valentine's Day stories about uh,
mistranslations translations,
et cetera. Valentine's Day is this week
when she says she doesn't need flowers,
she means you better get me flowers.
Okay, get we got bought a pain in the ass.
It is to go down to the dam flower store
with every other loser guy standing
there trying to get the last bit of a,
you know, the flowers are half dead.
All right? By the way, when the,
the more the flower is open,
the closer it is to death.
I see.
Learned that from the late great Patrice
O'neil who believe in are not used to
sell flowers at some point in his life.
He told me that and I never forgot it.
Anyways,
they got the fresh flowers here.
Pro Flowers get one dozen long stem
assorted roses with a premium vase and
gourmet chocolates for 29
99 or double the roses.
That's two dozen roses long stems and
the premium vase and chocolates for just
nine 99 more and you won't find a deal
this good anywhere else this week.
So for 40 bucks you get all that.
Okay?
Proflowers is quick and easy and
delivers on Valentine's Day deliveries on
Valentine's days, guaranteed. Even if
you already have Valentine's Day plans,
you need flowers. You got
to get them. It's the,
you put the Cherry on top and it's,
this is so perfect for guys.
It's so perfect.
All you gotta do is just order it.
You don't even have to
get away from your desk.
You can literally be watching the game
in between periods. You can order.
How do you do it? Here's the only
way to get the Valentine's Day deal.
One dozen long stem assorted roses with
a premium vase and chocolates for 29 99
or double the roses for just nine 99 more.
Go to proflowers.com click on the blue
microphone at the top of the top right
hand corner and typing burpee you are are.
That's proflowers.com click on
the microphone and type in Berbee.
You are are ordered today.
This deals is only around while
supplies last and Valentine's Day.
Is this Friday? Okay.
stamps.com everybody.
Oh Jesus stamps.com everybody
you've probably heard the
cost of stamps just went
up to 49 cents but not if
you have stamps.com with
stamps.com you pay less for
postage, uh, you,
you'll pay less for postage than you
were at the post office for First Class
Mail priority and priority
express mail packages and more.
stamps.com is easy to use and convenient
by imprint, discounted stamps,
shipping labels, and more using
your own computer and printer.
Not only will you save
money with stamps.com by not
paying full price postage,
you'll save valuable time to stamps.com
always keeps the rates up to date so
you'll so you'll get the exact postage
you need every time right from your desk.
Never go to the post office again.
I use stamps.com to send out
all my posters and my DVDs.
I've never had a problem right now.
Use My last name.
Burpee you are are for this special offer,
no risk trial plus $110 bonus offer that
includes a digital scale and up to 55
bucks free postage. You can't
miss with this one. Don't wait.
Go to stamps.com before
you do anything else,
click on the microphone at the top of
the homepage and type in [inaudible],
B u r r that stamps.com
enter burr freescale,
$55 postage hundred $10 offer.
That's what it's worth.
What am I trying to say?
You don't ever have to go to the
post office again. Don't be an idiot.
stamps.com all right.
Legal Zoom, everyone.
Some things like starting a business
or protecting your family with the will
aren't like your other
new year's resolutions.
You can't afford to blow this one off.
All right.
Instead of less snacking and
more exercise, put, put this
at the top of your list.
Legal Zoom helps you incorporate or form
an LLC with their simple questionnaire.
Starting at just 99 bucks.
Over 1 million entrepreneurs have
already done it and 90% of our customer
customers recommend legal
zoom to friends and family.
You can also create a will starting at
just 69 bucks or even a living trust
quickly and easily and get peace of
mind and protection. No surprise fees,
no hassles,
man and no headaches.
Legal Zoom step by step process was
created by a team of legal experts in law
and technology.
Legal Zoom is not a law firm but can
connect you with the third party attorney
and provides you with the self help
services from wills to business, sorry,
from wills to business formations,
trademark powers of attorneys and more.
Go to legal zoom.com for even more
savings type and bur bur are into the
referral box at checkout.
Don't put off the things you need to do.
Go to legal zoom.com now and use discount.
Use the discount code bur
bur that's legalzoom.com
discount code bar. All right,
and last, but certainly not least,
the voice. Everyone. All right,
you're a business.
Oh No,
but automated phone system and
secretaries are not in your budget.
They're not in your budget just yet.
And juggling incoming calls yourself did.
That doesn't make you look
like a professional, right?
You want to make money here. You want
to look like a pro. Here's what can,
here's something you could do that will
dramatically help you make more money.
In 2014 it's called a voice.
Everyone,
whether you're a business of one or 100,
he voice will help you manage all of your
incoming calls with a toll free number.
Dial by name,
directory and call routing tools.
Your business will sound like 1 million
bucks. Can't take a call, no problem.
He voice. We'll transcribe the
voicemail and email it to you. Uh,
never get caught off guard again.
And with the voice you can try
it before you buy it right now.
Just for my listeners, you can get
a 60 day free trial to eve voice.
Go to [inaudible] dot com and enter the
Promo Code Bill B I l l at checkout.
Take charge of your business and make
more money in 2014 go to [inaudible] dot
com and at your bill at the checkout
for your 60 day free trial. That's eve,
voice.com Promo Code Bill.
And that is the advertising
and with the magic of editing,
we are now returning to
the Monday morning podcast.
Okay.
Okay. And we're back. Ah,
how about those reads?
Will those things awesome or what? I
have no idea. I hope they went well.
Uh Oh, you know, the one that I always
forget to bring up is a amazon.com.
Everyone,
if you shop through amazon.com like I do,
if you'd like to donate to this podcast,
here's a wonderful thing you can do.
Just go to [inaudible] dot
com click on the podcast page.
You look over on the right,
there's the amazon.com a banner you
click on that takes you right to Amazon.
And I know it's an extra step, but uh,
if I drive track of traffic to this site,
they give me a kickback
on whenever you guys buy,
it doesn't cost Shani any more money.
I just takes a little bit of,
you're a little bit of life out of your
index finger with a couple of extra
clicks. That's all. That's all it is. If
you'd like to do it, do it. If you don't,
I understand you're busy.
You got shit to do. Uh,
all right, let's move on here. Hey,
how fucking weird and awful is right
after the super bowl that first Sunday
without football. I don't know about you
guys, but it's always so goddamn jarring.
MMM.
Because you're so watching the playoffs
and you're so getting into it and your
soul trying to guess who's going to
win the Superbowl and fucking get,
get your bets going and all of that shit
that you don't even contemplate that.
The second that game's over,
football is now done.
Okay,
dawn until September. Fuck that
bullshit in August. All right.
It's done until September.
What in God's name are we going to do now?
I'd say turn on the fucking hockey,
but it's the Olympics,
so,
oh, actually can actually watch women's
hockey because the men's hockey doesn't
start for a minute. Please.
Everybody. Do me a favor. Watch.
Some of that Olympic hockey sit down and
enjoy it. It's going to be phenomenal.
And when you do enjoy it,
don't say that dumb shit like,
like everybody says actually
tweeted about this, you know,
every four years during
the winter Olympics,
people who don't watch hockey
get to lie and say that if NHL,
if the NHL was like Olympic hockey,
that they would actually watch Olympic
hockey. You wouldn't, you would,
you were either a basketball
person or a hockey person.
There's very few people who have
the time to watch both. All right.
Another thing that always happens during
the Olympics is when people praise the
Olympic game, um, they
start talking about the NHL.
Like it's still 1975. I heard, uh,
Mike Wilbon who I love and one of the
few shows that I actually like PTI on a
ESPN. He even hinted like that. He goes,
it's great. I love the Olympic hockey.
You know, if the Nh, he goes, you know,
at the NHL would get the fighting and
all this stick work, all this stuff.
What does that mean? All the
stick work? What the fuck?
What does that mean? That guys are just
club and each over the fucking head.
You know why they say that? Because
once every four or five years goes by,
somebody does that shit actually club
somebody in the face with a goddamn and
then that's the thing that gets on sports
center and then all these people who
don't watch hockey at all or or or watch
it in passing then start going like
nice is a card game and they
always go in the fighting.
Dude, this, I've been
saying this for years,
I said this in 2010 during the Olympics
there's barely any fighting left in NHL
hockey compared to the way it used to be.
Okay.
Back in the day you used to have like
at least two if not three guys on every
team who are on your team to beat the
shit out of the other two to three guys
that were on that team to try to
beat the shit out of your guys.
Like when I was growing up,
when I first started watching the Bruins,
they had John went sick and Stan,
Jonathan and one of our all star players.
The heart of the team was Terry O'Reilly
and he fought just as much as he scored
back then it was,
he was known as a complete player.
He could do whatever you wanted to do.
You want the puck in the net.
I don't know how good he was a defense,
but whatever he gave it his all
you want to drop the gloves?
He could fucking do everything.
Wayne Cashman was another guy.
I mean he was like a gold score, that guy
and he, he, I just remember Fred Cusick.
Oh, Cashman with the left.
Yeah, this left hook. Um,
and then I caught the tail end of those
guys and then it was Jay Miller Linden
buyers
along the way.
We'd pick up guys like Willie
Plett and then the islanders.
The island has had all these guys.
Great Hall of fame, tough guys.
Chris Nilan, cordic everybody.
And then they weren't in
the same fucking team. Okay.
Now, like I don't even know
how many like actual goons,
straight up fucking fighters I want.
I'm not going to say goons are, are,
are still in the Goddamn league.
Like right now the,
the Bruins have one, Sean Thornton
and he can actually play the game.
I know a lot of you guys going
to say what's the why of what?
About what he did against the
penguins. That's going to happen. Okay.
Especially when you give somebody a
couple of love taps and they actually
somehow get knocked out.
I don't want to be a dick,
but I think I could have
taken those punches.
Oh wait, can we eat from
the peg? Would feds. Um,
and I know what they're going to be
saying is they're actually going to say,
well,
why is there fighting?
Why is there fighting in hockey? Which
is the dumbest fucking question. Never.
It's like you're going to
address that and say, well,
why is there fighting period.
Yeah.
Why is there fighting and boxing? Why is
there fighting in the UFC? Why is that?
Okay? But if every once in a
while it happens in hockey,
it's the most just,
you know,
deplorable fucking thing
that ever happened and now
you've got to make comments
on society and the
direction that is going in.
Okay.
Through the Bruins played the fucking
Canadians a couple of weeks ago and I'm
pretty sure there wasn't even
a fight in it. Those things,
by halfway through the first period,
once a year,
they'd have that game halfway through
the first period they would be like nine
guys in the penalty box and like fucking,
I don't even know if that's
even possible. They, they, they,
they would be standing room
only in the fucking penalty box
and now they'll play each other and
they just play the fucking game.
Okay.
Without having any fights. But the
fights are part of the Goddamn game.
And so I understand if you don't
like hockey because of the fighting,
but for the love of God,
please quit complaining about it
because they're ruining the game because
they're going to take fighting out of
it and you're not going to watch it.
You're not going to watch it. You're
going to watch it the way I watch curling.
I watch it once every four years and
I really enjoy it and I think like,
wow,
I could actually watch this sport.
Like I'm really going to go out and get
the curling package and start watching
it religiously every fucking year.
I'm not going to do it. All right,
so for the love of God, please enjoy
the Olympic hockey and watch it,
but keep you fucking uninformed comments
about the NHL to yourself because it's
an unbelievable game.
It's a great league.
And one of the reasons why it is so great
is because not as many people watch it
as the other three fucking leaks.
Nope.
I just love that people fucking still
bitch about hockey and like the fucking
NBA had a mobbed up ref literally
shoeless Joe Jackson kind of Shit and they
just gloss it over. I mean it was
a story, but it was like, well,
we had one bad apple,
one bad apple.
The fucking guy prevented the Sacramento
Kings from going to the finals.
The Lakers got another
ring or an opportunity.
I'm not taking away the fact
that they won in the finals.
What this fucking guy admitted
that he fixed the God damn series.
So they have,
they have a championship.
Just like when the white sox
through the world series,
you have the same thing going on except
it was done by someone on an officiating
crew and I,
you hear more shit about the fighting
and hockey than you heard about that.
It's unfucking believable.
I actually got a friend of mine
who will remain nameless
and he claims this,
I don't know why he would lie.
He was working for uh Oh,
this is tough. I gotta Watch out.
I'm going to get sued. He was warm.
He was working for a basketball team
that I'm not particularly fond of,
that I may or may not have made fun of
on numerous times and may have already
made fun of them on this podcast
about championship claims,
but I'm not going to say who they are.
They're way uniforms.
Remind me of Barney the dinosaur.
All right.
That's for anybody who doesn't
watch sports. You can't
figure it out. All right.
They worked at the arena and there was
one game left and this team was playing
another team that was up
north where it rains a lot,
but they didn't lose
their basketball team.
And there was one game left in the series
and the guy who just stepped down told
the people for the Barney the dinosaur
team to fucking order all the craft
service or something like that.
The fucking get the seats set
up for the media and all that.
But he only said it for the Barney,
the dinosaur team,
not for the rained out fucking team.
And the Barney the dinosaur team for like,
before the game even happened,
he was claiming that
there's no fuck cause he,
he knew somebody who was in
the, uh, the fucking, uh,
the other team's front office and they
were not given instructions to get
prepared for the next playoff series.
So it wasn't like we need to be prepared
just in case he only told one team to
fucking do it. And it ended up being
the team that won the, I know that,
that sounds fucking crazy. I'm not saying
it's true. I'm not saying it's not true,
but all I know is for fucking years.
I was saying the NBA is fixed and then
I'm vindicated when they have a fucking
mobbed up ref and it's
like a fucking God damn.
Like it was maybe a 10 day story.
It was really hard for a couple of days.
And then that was it. It just went away.
Oh, he's just had one to one fucking guy.
One mobbed up ref
fucking a team out of a championship.
That chance to win a championship.
That's all. But the fighting,
Oh and and the stick work, the,
the, the Tom foolery. It just has to stop.
You don't even have to watch hockey
at this point to criticize it.
So many people have criticized the fucking
thing. You can just say what they say.
All right, I'm done. I'm
done. I got my fucking,
I'll get my panties in a bunch of you. Um,
all right, let's, let's, let's read some,
uh, let's read some of the, that
the sh the shit here for the week.
Some of the, uh, the, the uh, what
do you call these things here? See,
this is another thing too.
That's my add.
I can't remember things
because they have add.
Why'd you take your Dick out in public
bill? I'm sorry. I got a date day.
Um, all right. Yo, Billy Dee Williams.
My chick is a diehard nine of fan
and after five years dating her,
I've gotten into my,
I've gotten into football myself.
Others consider me a
conspiracy theorist. Oh, Jesus.
Now we're going right
into conspiracy here.
Right after nine 11 I called it that
the Patriots would win to symbolize the
Phoenix style rebirth of
American patriotism. Sure enough,
the Patriots won. All right. I'm
going to go with you on that one,
dude.
I called it all right.
He said this year I made
another prediction that I
was really hoping would be
wrong. I had a feeling that
Seattle, the team icon,
which resembles the America's Bald Eagle,
will beat Denver's horse team,
which represents China's
Year of the horse.
This to symbolize the west domination
over the east to further support.
My previously stated theory.
They weren't.
There were a ton of pro soldier
and patriotic commercials.
I'm very curious to see what
political events are to come in.
2014 thoughts. Yeah, dude, your,
you're way too far down
the fucking rabbit hole.
Okay.
I've never understood that thing.
Like,
like the symbols on TV thing.
That's always,
to me it seemed like paranoid thought.
Um, and fuck everybody right now.
Who thinks my NBA shit, his paranoia,
they had a mobbed up ref go fuck yourself.
Um,
it was fixed.
I'm not saying straight across the board,
but it was fixed on a certain
fucking level. This shit here.
Like first of all.
Yeah.
All right. So yeah. Titles team which
resembles and American Bald Eagle.
It doesn't,
yeah,
it doesn't, we'll beat the
horse. I got to tell you,
I didn't know it was
the year of the horse.
And I think I pretty much
represent the average Joe and uh,
uh,
see gold doesn't,
a seagull does not look like
what's on the side of, of, of,
of the Seahawks and a single
fucking sea hawk. I'm an asshole.
I don't even realize, I was saying that
a sea hawk does not look like a fucking,
uh, a bald eagle. It
doesn't a real one doesn't.
The one that they showed looks nothing
like the cartoon version that they have
on the side of the fucking
head. And even if it does. Okay.
The average Shithead,
the way you have to spell stuff out,
I mean the average shithead is ordering
the Twat from nature there and having a
box of fucking chocolate covered
peanuts delivered to their desk.
They going to stick those in their mouth
and then wonder why they don't have abs.
Do you think they're going to be able to
figure out the American Bald Eagle and
the Denvers horse? I'm a
patriots fan. All right.
Like I don't think,
I just never made the connection.
I think you're, you're looking,
so you're saying the Illuminati
is also running a football league?
Yeah.
Now what if the Falcons won? What
would that, what does that have meant?
Okay,
the Green Bay packers.
What will you know,
do all of them symbolize something like
every year? Somebody who won last year,
who the fuck one last year? I don't even
remember. Usually good about that shit.
Two years ago the giants won.
I remember that.
Cause they beat my fucking patriots.
What does that mean that giants
are for the Taliban? Yeah, dude, I,
I think that your,
um,
I'm like if the 40 niners when it,
that means like we're
coming back to slave labor,
your load 16 tons and water,
you get big John Big jaw,
big bad drone. Uh, yeah dude,
I think that, uh, I think you're, you're,
you're kind of going beautiful mind there.
You're reading the daily paper
and you're trying to to see stuff.
Okay.
That isn't there.
Yeah.
To symbolize what the West
domination over the east. I gotta be.
I gotta be honest with you.
I don't understand, you know,
as far as I'm concerned,
China is west of where I'm at.
So how are they in the east?
Yeah.
I mean, when I fly to China, if I ever
go to China, I'm going to go west.
They're going to fly me up to Alaska,
make a left and then go
right by fucking South Korea.
Hopefully you don't get shut down as
we go by Russia and then I'm in China.
I'm not going to go east.
How did they decide that?
Is that because that's
where we will po populated.
Like if everybody came from Africa
like Nas and all the rappers say,
you know, cause they've done
their research in between blunts.
Um,
if we actually all came from there then
why doesn't the day start right there?
Cause I know,
I understand where you were living
on this fear that the world is round.
Who's to say where the day starts?
Why does it store Japan?
All right, sorry. There you go.
It was a nice little fucking minute and
a half to make you feel better about
yourself intellectually moving on.
Alright, championships in Seattle.
Billy Boldface,
I'm not sure if you heard about this,
but Seattle has a few championships
in women's basketball.
I'm obviously no one gives a fuck,
but this is what's great.
I imagine the women who play on the
team give a shit and those 37 people who
were related to him in the
crowd, I'm sure they do. Oh fuck.
That's too close to a
Joe Bart. Nick joke. Um,
yeah,
I imagine they give a
shit. Let's see. Says,
there's a great picture going on
around it, around have a headline.
Seattle's first championship from the
Seattle newspaper below the headline is a
picture of a player from the Seattle's
women's basketball team as she's looking
up at a bunch of banners for
championships that they've won.
Okay,
well don't they mean like the
Seahawks first championship?
Cause even if they aren't sexist,
when they realized that the
supersonics won a championship.
Dude, wait a minute. Do you not do,
do like not count that one now
because the sonics move to uh,
to Oklahoma City and became the thunder.
I don't understand that. Like, you know,
it was cool this weekend I saw somebody
in the crowd and a Minneapolis Lakers
tee shirt.
I thought it was great and I was telling
them I go those five championships. I,
you know, as far as fans
go, you guys claim those,
the franchise, you know, has
the trophies but the fans,
those are your championships,
right?
Has to be passed to fucking be
if, if the Lakers moved to fucking Las
Vegas. So one again next, next year.
What would the, what would Los Angeles
fans do if they started going, yeah,
we got 17 bitch. You'd be
like, well, wait a minute. No.
16 of those one in La and
then Minneapolis fans.
We have now five of those
11 championships. One in La,
five, one in Minneapolis. One
of them was in the fucking Ba.
Oh Jesus. Bill, let it go, man. I go fuck
yourself. I like, I like being a cunt.
Um,
so yeah,
I mean women's championships don't
count as much because of women.
It's their fault.
Okay.
Because guys don't sit around watching
the WWE NBA. We keep supporting the NBA.
What women need to do is say fuck the
NBA and just start watching the WNB ate.
And what they should be doing is they
should be selling out those arenas,
cheering on the women there.
That's who needs to do it.
Right.
Then they should all get together with
all their alimony money and they should
buy out the men that started the WWE
NBA and should run it themselves.
Yeah.
And then no longer do you need the
NFL to be wearing pink in October.
You could fucking be wearing
it all year and your league,
Jesus Christ.
I don't know if I just
solved some problems or a
offended everybody from cancer
survivors to uh,
people with the village over there.
Um, I don't give a fuck whatever, take,
take, take the podcast. Seriously. That's,
that's been happening lately.
The couple of native Americans get sent
me some angry tweets number a few weeks
ago when I was making fun of white
ignorance when I said that, uh,
Hawaii was not part of the United States
because no white people look right out
in Hawaii.
But you look fine on the mainland.
Like look leaning up against an oak tree.
I look fine and I'm like,
and I'm so sick and native American,
it's so,
I'm so sick of arguing with the patches.
I literally said that, that like,
like that wasn't enough. That wasn't
absurd enough for someone to get the joke.
People were, were like doing that,
you know, at Jim Norton Character,
a little literal gym. They
would, they were doing that like,
well the reason, well you look doable
cause you fucking killed all of us. Like,
I don't know that like I'm
somehow for that. I don't know.
Anyways, but whatever, continue to
take it seriously. I had actually,
somebody wrote me last week,
I said they,
I said fighting like a pitbull
and somebody wrote this
woman wrote fighting like
a pit bull.
Really?
You fucked her hard and she went
on and on and on and on and on.
And I wanted to write back, well
like okay, I rescued a pit bull pit.
Bulls were bred to fight
messiness. Right. Okay.
And lastly,
fuck Todd is a play on retard.
So it's okay to make fun of people who
are mentally challenged but not dogs get
twisted cunt. But I don't, I don't
write that back cause you know what?
They don't want Twitter. They don't
give you enough letters. Oh all right.
The Art of baking dear billion billion.
As of late, I've been baking. I
would never know how to say this.
Scones sconces of the things that are on
the walls and I only reason why I know
that was because I had to say that
one time at an audition. Scones.
He said, all right, I'll just
say scones. I don't give a fuck.
As of lately I've been baking
scones and he, right, right. Oh,
Jay z's are they good?
I got the idea from you and your
lovely Pumpkin Pumpkin. Loafs uh,
you sound so pumped talking about your
baking and it made me want to try it.
It certainly adds another dimension,
uh, to my game with the leg.
Oh, absolutely do. Let me
tell you something. One
thing, one thing about women,
all right,
other than the fact that they do not
support other women playing basketball,
at least they don't do it enough.
The other thing about women
is they like fucking suites.
Yeah.
Okay.
They love a guy that can cook.
If you can actually fucking
make something sugary,
it's great on two levels.
One,
it makes you seem like you're going
to be a good husband and father,
even if you're not, it just makes it seem
that way and they're more apt to bag.
Don't ask me why. I don't pretend to
understand them. Okay. And then secondly,
if you actually marry that woman when
she starts getting all fucking crampy,
you know, and getting all bitchy when
she gets the cramp toe still over there,
what you can do is just whip up a little
pumpkin bread, little sugar. Okay, you go,
here you go honey. Fuck machine in
her face. And then she, you know,
she's not as irritable.
It's an understandable
irritability. Don't get me wrong,
but believe me, I know there's a
lot of female comics will say, hey,
if you started bleeding from you dick
once a month, you'd be complaining too.
Yeah, and if I did and you didn't,
you'd be bitching about my mood.
So go fuck yourself. All right.
Um, so anyways, he says, uh,
nothing twinkle toes about
baking to impress a girl. Yeah,
it is. It's still very a
feminine baking is a feminine.
I don't care how you look at it.
There's nothing wrong with it.
You're getting in touch with your
feminine side. I'm so proud of you.
Here's another thing you can do.
Somebody sent me an email about this too.
You want to,
you want to really start slaying it.
If you have no fucking game and you need
to do something to make your franchise
look a little more attractive.
So maybe you can make one or two
big signings during this off season.
All right, learn how to
bake. And by all means,
take a fun start taking yoga classes.
Yoga classes are 98% women.
All right?
And I don't know what it is. Most of them
are fucking hot. Now a lot of you have,
granted I've taken yoga classes
in New York City and Los Angeles.
So there there's that.
So knock that down by about 30%.
Um, and also a lot of them are career
driven. So there's not a lot of moms in,
there's a lot of single
women in their very limber,
fucked in the head. Women, you know
what? Fuck that. Scratch all that.
Learn how to bake no matter where you are.
But take yoga and like Miami,
Take Yoga classes where there's going
to be a lot of hot women. They golf.
There's my stupid advice for
the week. Anyways, let's,
let's continue here. He said,
the ladies get turned on by a guy who can
cook slash bake because it exemplifies
our capability to follow instructions.
Parenthesis, recipe, and B,
they can tell by the texture that
you're good with your hands needing.
What are you gonna need?
Her titties
is fucking grabbing her ass
cheeks, you know, seven Lena.
Um, anyways, he says, thanks for letting
us in on that little secret. Hey Dude,
it's all you buddy. You fucking took
it and you ran with it. Um, yeah,
that's all that shit I'm telling
you right now. If you fucking,
if you want to upgrade the level of
ash and your life and you just look at
yourself in the mirror and you're like,
no matter what I do when I look at myself,
you know, I'm like, I'm like a six,
a five. If you, I'm Tony. If
you learn how to fucking big,
okay, just shit. You know what you do?
You learn how to make shit that they
like to eat. What's that? What's those?
Looks like Lasagna. It looks like
a pie, but it has eggs in it.
Quiche.
That was a called.
I can never fucking remember the old way.
I remember what that's called is I
remember the actor's Stacy Keach.
So that's the nickname for that shit.
Whenever I see it with Nia,
like we'll come walking in and I'll
look at the breakfast options and then
whenever I see it I just go stay and
she laughs for whatever fucking reason
cause she gets my sense of humor.
So you've learned how to do that.
Here's another one. All right. Learn
how to make red velvet pancakes.
I swear to God,
I'm not saying every woman likes this,
but you just increased by 2% your chances
of some day banging a model if you
know how to make red velvet pancakes,
okay?
Some tall woman will come into your life.
I'm guaranteeing it right now.
He got a 2% chance more.
She'll come into your life,
she'll eat those red velvet pancakes.
Okay? She will quickly go to the bathroom,
she will puke.
I'm up and then jump on your
Dick and you're not even
going to give a fuck. Okay.
Cause she's hard. Yeah, sorry. Um,
that was disgusting on so
many levels. Anyways, he says,
I'm looking forward to
seeing you in Ottawa.
Hopefully you get a chance
to escape on the canal. Uh,
Jesus Christ. If that doesn't sound
like the most feminine thing ever,
I'll fucking do that in a second.
He said you're always welcome to come
play hockey with us after the show.
Get the fuck Outta here.
Where I want to play.
I got two shows there I think.
Do Fuck that.
If there's a game after the
show in Ottawa, I want in.
Don't fuck me cause I'm,
I'm going to check my hockey shit.
Are you going to be mad at me if I play?
I have to play pond hockey with all my
hockey gear on because I'm in the middle
of a tour. I can't crack my
skull, my knee or my elbow there.
Um, to C'mon, let's do it and fight me.
Can I come over your house? I feel
like the kid with no friends. I'll do.
That'd be a great fucking youtube video.
All you Canadian guys out there
like no hats on street clothes,
skating all around me as I'm
out there looking like Robo Cop.
Let's fucking do it.
Versie not knowing how to skate.
Sitting there with a [inaudible] standing
on a frozen pond. I'm all over it.
All right, there we
go. Here's one from um,
about one of my favorite comedians
of all time, Doug Stanhope. He said,
Bill heard you. Gotta you got gotta shout
out on Doug. Stan helps podcasts. Uh,
what a great guy. I'll tell you
that Doug Stanhope, you know what?
Biggest Heart in the fucking business.
He's just a great fucking guy.
You really love about stand up.
He,
he's one of the best
comics of all fucking time.
Any still a fan of standup,
like actually will sit there and enjoy
watching you. Sets of fucking thrill.
Anytime that guy, he's given me
way too compliments a top shelf.
That's the Johnny blue of
compliments, right? They're
getting that from Stan hope.
Um,
okay.
He says, anytime I hear people
talk about your podcast,
they say it's cool that you
do it by yourself and you
can somehow keep it funny.
Love that you don't have guests.
Except it'd be cool if you have
Stan hope on some time. Yes, I know.
We have to make that happen. I
promise you that will happen. In fact,
I will text him at the end of this
podcast unless I forget and if I forget,
it's not my fault because I have add.
Oh Man. You know what? I
get to use it on my wife.
That'll be the funniest fucking shit ever.
I'm just going to start using it
as an excuse. And you know what?
She's going to laugh because
she has a great sense of humor,
but I'm going to do it until maybe five
days afterwards become already become
annoying just because those last five
days, it'll be fun for me and I'm selfish.
All right, Vermont. This one's
talking about for my bill.
I see you're coming to Vermont. Fucking
finally. No one ever comes up here.
Yeah. Well what, why
would you think that is?
How about the fact that you don't have
a comedy club? Unless it's part of a,
it's like a function. Roman at a hotel.
The only time I ever performed in Vermont,
I performed in a comedy zone in uh,
Burlington.
Yeah,
a long, long time ago. Like literally,
was it eight coming up on
like 18 years ago? Like 18.
Holy Fuck am I old?
Um,
I'm getting like scary old. That
was 18 fucking years ago. Holy Shit.
Holy Shit. Yeah. Well you guys don't
have a comedy club with their, what?
The 41 from me. All you have is that
beautiful land. You Syrup your foliage.
Um,
it's not like I haven't come to Albany.
Why don't you get in a car
and come down to civilization?
I got to go up there to your fucking
moonshine still. And he goes, he goes,
so how are you going to pass the time?
I don't see you as someone who fantasizes
about shooting a moose. I know you're,
you're drinking,
but Fremont has what's considered,
I guess you meant not drinking,
but Vermont is considered, uh,
what's considered the best beer in the
world right now? It's called heady topper.
Holy Shit, Bill. It's good storage.
Get their shipment Tuesday and sell
up by Wednesday. It's fucking awesome.
Here's an article I'll give you guys the
link so they can sell out in the same
day. Uh, also what, what are you x?
What are your experiences
with Vermont? Um, I,
I love Vermont am I, I'm a New
England guy. I grew up out there.
I go to Vermont and I think I
would love to own a house up here.
I'm sorry if I could somehow
survive in this business.
Um,
you know,
I would live in a p I would
live in a place like that.
I think I would go a little bit crazy
cause I definitely need a little bit of
action. I def I liked the city. I mean
I'm a suburb guy. I'm not a country guy.
So,
um,
I dunno dude, that actually sounds great.
If I could get a fucking log cabin,
I know you don't live in log cabins
out there, but uh, I don't, you know,
it was fucking business.
I, you know, I'm tired man.
I did a lot of roadwork
and the more road you do,
just the more you,
you need a fucking vacation.
But once you start selling tickets
on the road, you get afraid.
If I take a fucking week off, they
going to move on to the next guy. Um,
you know, I actually had somebody, uh,
some email I was reading and they were
complimenting my act and they said,
hey bill,
do you ever think some young
whippersnappers going to
come along and pass shoe
and replace you? Uh, absolutely.
Absolute fucking lutely.
It always happens if Jordan
can get too old for the NBA.
I can't get too old for standup,
you know, at some point,
no matter how much you stay informed,
you know,
you're going to be doing those
matinee shows with whoever's,
we'll still alive from
your fucking fan base.
I don't mind it. Um,
it's supposed to happen.
What I'm supposed to do is pickup the
comedy torch and run with it as far as I
can. And when I collapsed, I
fucking hold it up like the dude,
try not to spill his white Russian.
We've got a beverage here, man. Um,
and then the next person comes along,
they grab it and they run with
it and you fucking cheer him on.
Tell him to take it to the next level.
And you know why that is sir?
Because standup does not belong to me.
It's not mine.
It's an art form. It's a privilege to be
able to do it and make a living at it.
So I try to respect that and I'll do it
as long as I can, but like, you know,
I mean shit,
it fucking happens to everybody, which
is why I don't have the new cell phone.
It's why I drive a seven year old. The
hybrid. I only have one fucking TV.
You hear Echo Echo in my
fucking house because um,
I all my money goes to pay
in this fucking thing down.
So, uh, cause I know
that day's going to come.
That fucking day's going to come
where I'm going to be sitting there.
You don't want me anymore.
But what about the show?
I did 96 in Vermont. Um,
yeah, it happens to everybody.
All right.
I guess that's why he's supposed to have
kids some day so you can watch them,
you know, pass it onto them.
That is one of my goals though.
I never want to become some bitter person.
I always want to be cheering on.
Okay,
whoever's coming next, you know,
that's the way you should be.
You shouldn't be a fucking
Dick about it. Um, you know,
and then also knowing that they're
coming, that drives you like,
let's see how long I can keep these
fucking plates spinning before they,
and eventually my arms are gonna get
tired and we read them. We finished. Ah,
Jesus. That's depressing. Whatever. What
are you gonna do? All right. Swimming.
Hey Billy White thighs. Ah,
Shit. That one actually hurts.
It's fucking true fucking
wallpaper piece there. Um,
do you ever think about installing
a lap pool? Yes, I have.
Before we bought this house, I looked
at another house and they had it there.
I didn't like the house, but I love
that. I think that that would be great.
Not like a lap pool. You mean like
the thing where you basically,
it's like long enough for you to lay down,
unless you're a basketball player and
just start swimming and you're swimming
against this current one of those ones.
What do you mean literally
a pool he says anyways,
or maybe joining a gym that has a pool.
It's a full body workout.
Anytime I see old dude's swimming,
I imagine they're really healthy.
I knew stormers in college and
they ate and drank like animals,
but they were always really cut
because they swam miles every day.
I think the hardest part of getting into
the gym and to a gym pool routine is
having to see other people.
Also,
the first few times when you're
inevitably tired, after half a lap,
plus there's no sharks in the water.
Um,
I love what you guys even write it in
the Boston accent now be said so we don't
have to hear you cry
about your inner fears.
My interferes is getting old and weak.
So I started swimming and it's great.
Uh, see how we brought that back
around. Very nice. Very nice.
Um, yeah, no, dude, you're
doing yourself a service.
You really are.
Uh,
I am a firm belief that you
should work out your entire life.
We should always do it.
I mean,
I'm not saying go out and still play
full court basketball. I mean, in your,
even your thirties or 50s, just get Shin
splints. It's fucking up your feet. Uh,
I think that you should do some form
of exercising. I love swimming. I, um,
I,
I am concerned about,
I guess Olympic swimmers haven't died
of any cancer. So the chlorine I guess,
isn't that bad. But that is one
thing when you jump into a pool,
you're jumping into a bunch of chemicals,
but I guess that's better
than jumping into a,
you know what the chemicals are killing.
So we'll leave it at that. Yeah.
You know what?
You don't want to look that up right now.
Let's look up what one of those
little stationary lap things are.
See what this is for the
person who has everything.
And then I want to do what might the
final advertising for this fucking week.
All right, what do we got
here? Let's see here. Lap Pool.
Let me just look this up. Oh, there it is.
Cost of lap pools. What? Fuck you
get the fuck Outta here.
This is 17 foot swim.
Spa is $23,900.
They call it an endless pool.
Are you fucking kidding
me? Oh, Jesus Christ.
All this shit just popped up
when I went on this website.
Now I know I'm going to get
all these fucking spam emails
about endless pool fucking
yeah,
we'll ever see this.
The 17 foot endless pool spa features
a large exercise area that is ideal for
swimming,
aquatic exercise and fun with easy access,
full depth stairs and up to two jets.
And with over 20 jets,
you can exercise,
relax and enjoy increased
family time in the Convenia.
You ever want to Piss with your whole
family? Let's get a lap pool. Um,
improve your health and wellbeing
on an endless pool. Right?
Here's the dimensions.
17 feet,
bye. Uh, well I guess now they're
doing an interest to 204 inches,
which comes out to 17 feet by 91 and
a half inches by 54 and a half inches.
I guess that's how deep
it is. Hey, what the fuck?
I don't even want to say in the 54
south, five feet deep, isn't it?
What does that four feet,
four and a half.
I love this shit here.
This thing is $23,000 and they have a
little button here that says add to the
cart like this other shit that you're
going to be getting with this. All right.
They have a 10 foot one.
Oh my God.
Oh Shit. This is, you might as well
just to use that place to take a dump.
How much is this one
add to cart? 15,009 A. Fuck you.
I'll go jump on a god damn dirty pond.
I guess it is amazing that you,
you're, you're, you're, you.
You're literally swimming against
the current. That doesn't exist.
Alright, hit. Now you get
into some cheaper ones here.
Here's, here's the fucking,
the high day version for 10 grand.
Oh,
that thing's a joke. What
is it? Is that a hot tub?
Oh, go fuck yourself. Well, yeah.
You know, I guess I thought about it.
I've definitely thought about,
now that I know how much it costs,
Holy Shit.
I have to take a fucking second mortgage
on my house to get one of those.
They are coolest shit though. Images for
lap pools. Dude, why did you do this?
Now I'm getting now I'm going to sit here.
Look at that one.
That looks like a real pool.
Oh, that is a real pool.
Who the fuck lives here? Mark? Spitz
keeping fit with home lap pool.
That's it.
Now you don't give a fuck about your kids.
If you got one of those,
you get this skinny pool that nobody
can jump into without breaking their
goddamn next. And it's for you
and your fucking gray chest hair.
Oh,
whatever you do.
You guys really want to sit here and
listen to me fucking reading about lap
pools while those things
are cool as hell though. Um,
yeah,
I,
I thought about getting one until I saw
how much they were and now that I know
how much they are, I am not. I am no
longer interested. I need a friend.
I need a rich friend with a
fucking lap pool. Good Lord.
Just a pool in general.
How fucking cool is that
fucking indoor pool? Indoor
lap pool. Who's his fucking
banker who has this shit?
Indoor lap pool?
You know,
it's funny with me. I would do.
I would get one of those. Okay.
Let's just say I could afford that.
I get one of those fucking
things and then within
a month I'd be bored and I
would go and do something else.
I'm the worst.
Okay.
I'd still owe all that money.
Tranquil lap pool.
Jesus Christ. You know what? I'm
going to look at these fucking things.
Anybody out there sell lap pools?
How many fucking,
how many of these do you sell a month?
Jesus Christ.
I'm going to get it on one of those
fucking home makeover shows. All right.
I want to have him Redo the wiring in my
house and fucking put in a lap pool and
then I'll go there and I'll
fucking act. Oh my God. A lap pool.
Jump around and hug everybody
that fucking did it. You know,
get on pimp my pool, whatever the fuck
this show is. All right. Who gives a fuck?
All right. Anyways, that's the, uh, that's
the podcast for this week. Everybody.
Um, I hope you enjoyed it. I hope you
learned something. I hope it was funny,
even though I did it on a Sunday.
And if you didn't learn anything,
it's not my fault cause I got
a d d o media. Ah, that's it.
That's a podcast for this week.
Go fuck yourselves. And um,
please watch the Olympic hockey speeds
gate and curling and all that shit.
Enjoy the Olympics. You know,
even though the water doesn't run,
even though they don't like gay people
over there, God dammit, these athletes,
they worked that whole fucking lives for
this shit. Give him a look. You know,
Alison a look, whatever the hell
you got to do. All right, I'm out.
Go Fuck Yourself.